so explain to me or I dunno now explain
to George and everybody else your new
obsession for all the movies on shudder
what's that you know what shudder is
basically a streaming service that's
kind of like Netflix but they only show
kind of horror movies cool and I don't
know what because um first of all I like
the genre I've always enjoyed the genre
I like adventures I like superhero
movies I like um some dramas but
generally I like or I've loved horror
movies as a kid I remember me my cousin
uh Jenny and Sue this is when Empire
Strikes Back came out mm-hm and I
remember going with Jenny in suit to the
movies and I remember them going let's
watch Evil Dead and I go no I want to
watch Empire Strikes Back and I'm making
a big stink of it and then when we're
watching Evil Dead I peed in the theater
to make them mad
wait how where what in the middle of the
movie theater I know we're on the floor
on the floor seat oh yeah yeah and then
I remembered Jenny didn't talk to me for
years after that but yeah I was that
kind of yeah
whenever Empire Strikes Back came out
ten years old okay or ten I thought as
long as you weren't like an adult that
was uh 36 36 I was 36 when I did that no
but then I remember after peeing on the
floor to be rebellious watching the
movie and being really scared of it and
then I saw Evil Dead 2 and then Evil
Dead and then I saw army of Darkness but
then I saw sis all that stuff I really
kind of grew up watching and so I've
been watching Shutter movies and uh some
of them have been not for everyone
they're not for everyone there are some
of them are very weird or also it's just
one movie that he was watching late at
night at 3 in the morning and as I was
falling asleep I just so happened that I
was like facing him like laying down so
I was like facing his iPad like this as
he was watching yeah I was like drifting
off and I swear to you it was the
scariest scene I had ever seen in my
whole life
I couldn't I had nightmares that night
and it was an argentinian film called
was it terrified terrified yeah I have
to highly recommend it doesn't you're
not gonna at the end of the there's no
resolution
obviously you don't really understand
fully what's going on in this movie even
though you know I like subtitled movies
but I have to say there are some really
creepy scenes and scenes what I like
about foreign for horror movies is they
they show things and they things that
American audiences narak n'mu V is
wouldn't show they'll they'll like
they'll linger on an image a little
longer or they'll make a choice in the
movie that I don't think that American
audience with audiences generally would
like because they're a little too weird
or or ghoulish to look at but um I
really enjoyed terrified if you have if
you like horror movies it's from
Argentina and it's a really good movie
and then I saw another one that you know
was a found footage you know mean horror
movie you know much like The Blair Witch
it was called no no Roy the curse no
it's called no Roy and and and translate
it's called the curse and it's basically
um what I like about it is you know even
when you watch was that what M night
Shyamalan we that we saw no the visit
which is kind of like handheld camera
supposedly but there are certain shots
where you go you know obviously it's not
from that you know mean camcorder it's
too right yeah the north of course every
bit of it is through just an
investigative can cool camcorder it's a
cool this yeah and it's um a lot of it
um is boring not boring but it's just
like because it's so realistic in my
opinion it's very shaky at times there's
stuff in it that's like you're you don't
even know why what quite is going on but
I'll tell you why I like the movie
is there is a constant mood in it mm-hmm
there's a sense there's just a sense a
sense of dread in the movie and because
it looks so real and um I'm sorry but
I've said this before I'll say it again
when Asian people get possessed by a
demon it's scarier scariest thing it's
like yeah it's a girl like just normal
you know Japanese girl they did you know
in you know they just there's something
about it maybe it's they're a little
funny looking eyes or I don't know what
it is but it's like it it really gets to
me
it really gets to me so I really
recommend that if you can get through
the real shakiness of the camera I was
starting to have a little bit of fear
though or I was starting to question our
parenting skills because the movies that
we've made Jules watch in this week
alone
I let me tell tell me tell me if this is
an okay if this is appropriate parenting
I saw the devil have you seen that the
Korean revenge film very gory min-sik
Choi isn't it if you haven't seen I saw
the devil you have another thing coming
yeah it really is a horrific masterpiece
I saw the devil then we made her watch
seven then old boy then mid-sole Mar
he's the Matic threat of these films
amid so Mar and a fight club and then
Fight Club Mike looks great but still
also very dark yeah it's very dark but
there are no rom-coms here Gil and I
know that you and I were very much when
we Jules feel about this does she like
this she does like the movies I mean
yeah I mean here's the thing about Jules
and she's such a nice person at heart
she's a pure soul she really is she's
just you know there's nothing really
negative about her she has a good
attitude and you know she kind of zones
off in her video games like she's doing
now but you know she is a good person
Yeah right and I don't fully you know I
I you know I think there needs to be
some sort of
complexity and you have to see see
certain things in life is hard there's
some dark that's how you teach like is
that as I'm saying what do you guys
think is it like approps that we only
show her gory films I mean yeah because
you you know there's certain things that
you learn from gory film what you know
what you do if that you you come across
a serial killer what you do when you
hear you're mean a chair moves in your
room and no one's you know they're just
right what you do if you realize you
have a split personality and you start a
fight club how to react it exactly right
exactly you have to look at the phone
records see who called you got to go to
different cities and go was I hear you
know how why do you sleep diagonally
baby I still have them trying to figure
that out I do sleep diag it's Mike
I either sleep in full my knees to my
chest
yeah right and then like this yeah